ليس بالضبط المعبد الحديث
لأفروديت الذي تشتهر به ميكونوس
لجزيرة الحفلات ، بالكاد تستيقظ
بعد أسبوعين من إعلان الموسم السياحي الرسمي
، لا تزال المتاحف مغلقة العديد من المتاجر
مغلقة
ولكن البعض الآخر يحصل على تجديد بينما
تخطط لإنشاء أكثر من  80 جزيرة خالية من
كوفيد قيد التنفيذ
إنها محور عملية الحرية الزرقاء.
الخطة اليونانية للانتعاش الاقتصادي
المدفوعة بالسياحة
قبل الوباء
كان يعمل خمس السكان في الصناعة
التي ولّدت 18 في المائة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
مع كوننا الزائرين الأمريكيين أكبر المنفقين في اليونان.
اعتمادًا على زيادة الصيف في عدد
الزائرين الأمريكيين
وشركات الطيران الأمريكية تعمل على زيادة الرحلات الجوية
إلى اليونان هذا العام من نيويورك ،
شيكاغو ،
فيلادلفيا نيوارك وواشنطن العاصمة
[موسيقى
] ، المفتاح هو حملة تلقيح قوية
لكسب كل مقيم في
الجزيرة بنهاية شهر يونيو
حتى يتمكن الزوار من  تعال إذا تم
تطعيمهم بأنفسهم
ونجوا من العدوى أو لديهم PCR سلبي
اختبروا يسمون هذه أيرلندا المجانية ، إنها
جزيرة خالية من الغطاء
وننتظر وصول جميع
السياح إلى ميكونوس للاستمتاع بالشواطئ
للاستمتاع بالحياة
التي تنجزها ، وقد يعتمد على إنهاء
اللوائح الوطنية التي تحظر
الموسيقى والحشود.
إنه يمتلك أيضًا العديد من النوادي الليلية والفنادق في ميكونوس التي يتصل بها عملاؤه مع سؤالين
خاصين من أمريكا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء يسألون عما إذا كنا قد تم
تطعيمنا وثانيًا إذا كان بإمكانهم الاحتفال
في الجزيرة
كما اعتادوا على حفلة اللقاح ، نعم
هذا هو  وصفة سحرية
حول 18 يونانيًا تم تطعيمهم بالكامل ،
حالات الطمع
الجديدة تتناقص والوفيات حوالي 40
يوميًا ،
ولكن الآن على الرغم من أن النوادي فارغة ،
إلا أن هزازات الكوكتيل يولدون أي
جرعة إيقاعية من cersei للتخفيف من موسيقى البلوز.
يبذلون قصارى جهدهم للاستمتاع بشاطئ
بدون ديسيبل من موسيقى الرقص
ولكن مع تطعيم أكثر من نصف السكان
، تتجه كل العيون إلى  بعد
إطلاق العنان
لديونيسوس والسماح للمتعة بالبدء في يوليو ليس
بالضرورة أن يشعر السائحون بالأمان من أجل
التعليق على
الحفلة والشعور بالأمان كما تعلم لأنه على
سبيل المثال في العام الماضي
كان الناس مستعدين للاحتفال ، كان من
الصعب علينا فرض  قواعد عليهم
ولكن أعتقد أننا جميعًا مدربون الآن
كعملاء وموظفين كل فرد ، لذا
أعتقد
نعم ، سيكون هذا صيفًا أفضل ،
هناك الكثير من الحديث في ميكونوس حول
كيف أن الأجواء لن تستمر
حتى بصوت عالٍ  تبدأ الموسيقى ولكن للمسافر الأكثر
نضجًا
الذي لا يمكن إلا أن يكون
سام كايلي مريحًا
لك في ميكونوس